taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them how you doing babe
hey everybody Welcome to wait is this
the beginning
all right we rolling let's leave all
this in leave this wooden leave one yes
everything that just happened up to what
point yeah
yeah leave all that in when you do no
what you just said when you said how you
doing babe and I said just that yeah not
the 20 minutes before it no no we're
right where you said so sorry babe and
you said welcome so where are you doing
are we rolling so we're already in we're
in this is the podcast now this is the
podcast this is
d-a-s-d-e buds
uh can I can I make like a duct and vent
I just made that up
you could use that if you want a duct
yeah like a duck like an air duct
I think you mean you wanted to vent
about something yeah that's what I meant
oh okay I was gonna make like a duck no
I guess yeah I don't know I mean it's
yeah go for it you know I just was being
silly go for it
Nike customer customer service I just
can't take it anymore to go in on Nike
though I'm gonna but I'm saying it's not
just them it's all customer service the
only people that I don't have the only
people I usually don't have an issue
with is Amex other than that if you call
customer service be ready to get nothing
resolved I'm not telling I'm teaching
anyone doesn't know get nothing resolved
waste anywhere between one to five hours
and get off the phone and have thoughts
like impure thoughts yeah you know his
customer service is great and I'm not
just saying it because they sponsor us
uh betterhelp has very good customer
service very responsive and they they
you know well they're in that business
it would be bad if they didn't have
yeah they're called better help yeah I
know but I was I was very happy with
like oh wow that's really nice okay but
not just because oh it's the business of
of of what they do but I was also like
you just don't find this look there are
plenty of things you deal with related
to your health and some capacity where
the customer service is terrible oh my
God your health insurance all the worst
people no but like I talked to this guy
at Nike and first of all
I think that someone should make a
document I mean everyone goes to this I
know everyone does but like the last 10
customer service calls I had I was on
hold the person was a a goddamn
they they transferred me that and then
you know you know you know when you get
put on hold you know the call is getting
dropped it's 10 out of 10 across 10
different companies they go well we're
gonna I said before you put me on hold
what happens if well that's not gonna
happen What happens if someone will be
like well do you have a callback number
they don't call back someone like I have
the notes here I'll get right back to
you they don't how about when you go
take my number in case I get
disconnected for the third time today
and they go we can't we can't yeah well
I'll call you well I'm I'm at a desk in
Tallahassee I'm not there well okay give
me the number we're not allowed to give
out the number well do you have an
employee number yeah it's uh I'm noting
your account you know what's you know
what you know what you should do you
should take rip off your own balls and
shove them down your throat and don't
know at any account just shove your
balls down your throat suffocate
yourself and die
you see this there's a national customer
rage survey that tracks customer
satisfaction and it says that is three
quarters of Americans say they've had
product or customer service problems
over the past year of course it's dude
you're seeing the rage is unbelievable
because it's almost like you're talking
to someone that is being irrational with
you it's an indicative of the CL of the
impending collapse but I don't want to
go down that dystopian Road it's also
it's also a matter of like is this worth
my time like now now it's like now I
don't call customer service when I
should when I have an issue that I don't
think is worth my time whatsoever and
then where is that sliding scale let's
say I have a problem with something and
it was a purchase and the purchase was
200 bucks
and I got it on the phone and wait an
hour get this connected call back and
then wait for someone to email me and
talk to a supervisor and all it's just
like what yeah so my nephews were
visiting me last week
and we went on Nike and we made five
pairs of shoes each like I made a
different pair that you could do your
own custom shoes and so we did one with
each I did one with my four and a half
years and and nice basically and uh it
took they were with me for a few days
and we it took a while you know they're
they're 8 10 12 and then the others are
older but like
you know okay now what about this and
what about this and what what it's we
went from color to case you want a
canvas you want sat and you want leather
you would the laces did it it's so many
options we crafted these shoes
five it took us hours and hours and
hours I placed the order five pairs of
custom-made shoes you can imagine it the
price point was like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of dollars yeah
um
pay for it six hours later I got an
email from Nike after I got the
confirmation email it's just the cop the
the the the the email said your shoes
are fire and then confirmed six hours
later
your order has been canceled
if you have if you think this is wrong
call this number that's all it said in
the body of the email I'm thinking this
is a dedicated line they get this all
the time it's wrong I don't know what
happened but I'm gonna call this person
tell them they're gonna fix it
a call it's an automated service
I get to go through all those prompts
then a guy picks up finally and he could
be he might as well be answering any
questions for anybody and he's it's not
the case where he's speaking like broken
industry he's hard to understand because
that happens sometimes but he's just
sounds like a like a lazy
yeah that's most most people he's like
huffing and puffing and like taking his
time like if I ask him something five
times on the call that I asked him
something I waited an uncomfortable
amount of time in silence and then I
went are you still there five times and
he goes yeah
so I would ask him a question and then
it'd just be silent silence I'm talking
about what 20 seconds and I go hello and
he goes yeah and you would think after
the first time that that happened yep it
wouldn't happen four more times I'd say
look
I made these shoes I paid for them and
it got you know so just put it put put
that thing back in he goes he goes what
happened I go I don't know he goes well
we go through it takes 15 minutes for
him to even suggest what might have
happened and he goes oh your billing is
different than your shipping I said okay
he goes well you know sometimes they
flag that I go okay
and he goes well you know you can't have
your billing your shipping has to be the
same as you're building I go so nobody
could buy anybody anything if I want to
buy anyone to give then mail it to them
I can't add the mail to my house and
then he's like no I'm like so then put
it through he goes well you know what
maybe your shipping address your billing
address was wrong you wrote me the
billing address I'm like it's 100
correct
he goes all right well he goes you want
me to escalate this I said Joe you can't
help me which this is the I had an order
was canceled this needs to be escalated
yeah he goes yeah hold on he goes on a
hold for five minutes right up why did
why have you been talking to me if you
can't handle it he goes on hold the hold
right I'm just waiting by the way one of
the holds this was so weird I texted him
one of the holds music was the best show
I was like baffled I don't know how was
wait Tom sharply I heard his voice and I
was like what is this time show was just
playing yes
so but but so then that but then other
times it was pure silence so one time on
hold for five minutes and I go hello and
then he goes he comes back and goes yes
we're here he goes we are we're working
on this I go you're working on what
escalating it he goes yeah I go what do
you got to do like you escalate it so he
takes another break comes back and then
he goes
he goes all right I'm going to escalate
this someone will call you I said what
do you mean bro I said I place an order
you canceled it just place it and he
goes well I can't I go why can't you he
goes I don't have the authority I go
what are you talking he goes all right
then then he comes back he goes all
right let me see if I could do it right
and then he goes what is the shoe code
for each shoe that you design and I go
it's not in the email I don't know he's
like all right well then you got to hang
up with me redo all the shoes and I was
like are you insane I don't even
remember them all and it took hours and
hours and hours I'm trying to give you
hundreds of dollars like this this is
the worst thing as a and he's like all
right and he goes um
sounds like the guy just didn't know
what he was doing he goes no so I'm on
the phone it's 21 minutes in and he goes
let me put you on hold I said what if I
get disconnected he goes I promise you
you won't get disconnected he puts me on
hold oh boy he came back because I said
where are you three times so he came
back three times but at the 25 minute
Mark of hold 46 minutes into the call he
he had gone off and he goes he comes
back and he goes I just want you to know
I'm here and I'm working on it and I he
says that and I go okay I said but
I'm not going to get hung up on right he
goes no
he goes away
and usually you hear like a click and a
dial tone or right he goes away and all
of a sudden I hear the main prompts
and you know I can't get back to him he
didn't give me any identifier it gets
sourced everywhere I go through all the
prompts again I get a woman who now is
not a dick and and seems like she can
help me but also she's like I had to go
in with you on this thing and do it one
by one together
so I stay on the phone with her
for another 40 minutes one by one shoe
by shoe doing this all
she puts it in I'm on the phone an hour
and 22 minutes
I actually took a screenshot because I
was like if I have to send this to
someone an hour and 22 minutes and she
goes is there anything else I can help
you with today I'm like that was
everything I was like I never expected
to spend hours on this and then get on
the phone and she goes all right she
goes now if if it gets canceled again
this is what she says if it gets
canceled again just call I put a note in
your account
what do you mean if it gets canceled
again you put it through she goes yeah
but even us sometimes will get flagged I
go what is going on over there I just
spent hours to make them and then over
an hour with you and you're telling
yourself
because my shipping address was
different than my building whose isn't
everybody's shipping address
and I said wait why wouldn't you tell me
at the beginning of this 40 minutes ago
that even though you're going to put
them in one by one with me it might
still get canceled she goes I go so how
do we avoid getting it canceled she goes
I can escalate it I go the first guy
who's going to escalate it what does it
take to escalate because I just got to
make a note and they have to call you
back I go so escalated she goes out you
know what I'll escalate it no matter
what so I go but what if you get
escalated they think I have a problem
then they cancel the order because the
problem more than that she's like I
don't know so I just was like I cannot
believe that this might get canceled
again and it's just I hung up after an
hour and 22 minutes and I wanted to
locate the sales office the service
office and I would go up there with
maybe like I don't know like a wiffle
ball bat filled with wet newspaper maybe
like we did as kids something that's
not going to hurt anyone too bad and I
would just start swinging it
but maybe I would do property damage
first this is what I spent the next
seven minutes thinking of there's also
there's also I mean I don't I don't know
that this was a case of it but like
banks for instance and I think Airlines
do this they a lot of them have this
policy where they say uh
obstruct the complaint by the caller and
if and if they call back three times
then assist them because that's a method
because people get discouraged and they
just won't that boils my blood so so but
but something like this with Nike which
I I actually don't think that's what
they're doing what I think they're doing
is I think that we have we have barreled
at light speed into such a compromised
digital living Society where everything
is accessible and compromisable from
every angle that this is some security
measure they're taking because there is
such a fraud problems and look this was
a terrible experience and it's Nikes too
with sneaker heads and like you know
people collecting even this is not even
close to the worst of the worst that
I've experienced there were times that I
had a breakdown because I needed to get
through to these people and it just
couldn't now and how is it how is it
that nine out of ten times you will get
disconnected when they put you on hold
how is that do you think that's not them
being like all right so it's all right
I can't call them back I don't know who
it is oh I love this one policy they
they make you put in your account
numbers everything oh please put in this
information so that we're prepared yeah
and then they ask you for it again I
know I have nothing
I've yelled the guy and go why did I
type that all in I'm not doing it again
why did I type it all in yeah and they
go uh we're really sorry sir it's just
it's just the way it works everything is
oh you're in the wrong Department let me
transfer you to that department I go am
I gonna have to explain that for 15
minutes again what just happened no I'll
go let's let them know hello blah blah
blah hey
do you know who I am do you know no no
what's the story I said I have to tell
you this all again we're living it's we
are living in a compromised society and
everything has to be confirmed and
reconfirmed and reconfirmed second third
fourth fifth time I am so sick of it I
am so sick of every time I want to log
into anything it's shooting codes to my
phone uh I need a backup password I have
to answer my own security question
everything it's everything all the time
and all of these methods some of them
are just we're we're trying to filter
out people that don't have the
wherewithal to fight the fight to get
their the justice for their
bad experience or whatever so we'll
it'll disconnect and who cares and blah
blah blah but a lot of this is
yeah you had to say it on the line just
to get through to the person and now the
person needs the info again to reconfirm
itself sure some of them don't even give
you the option for a person you just got
to know to hit zero or hit a bunch of
buttons till look at the world we live
in dude when's the last time when's the
last
just something as stupid as concert
tickets
something as stupid as concert tickets
that you have to take into consideration
I will probably have to buy these from
some third party
even if I I'm not waiting until the day
of or anything like that but if you do
use game time yes yes and I'm not
talking about game time because game
time is game time is designed to help
you find the best deal right I'm talking
about like StubHub where it's like oh so
stubhub's just part of it now like
StubHub just running wild with prices
and gouging everybody because because
they have machines and and and and
computer out uh uh programs that can go
in and buy every ticket instantly in
three minutes like I just have to deal
with that now oh I want the PlayStation
7 I just have to accept that they will
all be purchased immediately by a
machine and then you know that some
scalper has and then I have to just go
and and pay 400 over asking price for it
if I want the thing within the first two
years of its release
who are they and what happened shame on
the corporations too that they don't
that they don't I mean what you went
through oddly is to me in my opinion is
Nike actually trying to do the right
thing where they're like look man it's
not about people
it's not about it you send me an email
if this is an error call us I call it
should be like it's an error no problem
you're good thank you I know but not 82
minutes the person not having the
authority and all that I honestly do
think that's Nike trying to trying to
create a secure thing for customers it
sucks that that's what it's come to but
the guy didn't even he he was a
and that's that's a different they hire
morons they're not they don't have no
choice they have to not pass they don't
have a test buddy also also if you you
know what look at me if you're in
customer service and and you're
listening and watching and we know that
you are if you're
what is wrong with you like you probably
have this exact same experience when you
call other customer service when you
need help as a human being why don't you
take a page out of that experience and
be the customer service person that you
want to see in the world
is it wake up customer service
stop calling it service it's multiple
factors it's it's like what's the on the
one hand I get annoyed because I'm like
do your job and do it well and then the
other hand I'm like well of course this
person doesn't want to do their job who
the hell wants they're not getting a
commission they don't get anything out
of this like this job sucks and then all
day they're dealing with people angry
but then just hiring angry zombies I
mean like do dude dude
listen
and is it is it being recorded for
quality assurance my whole life you've
told me you've recorded me for quality
assurance where is it where is the
Assured Quality I know no I had a I had
a I had a bit about that about how like
the the automated surveys and all that
doesn't it does nothing because nobody
is listening to the tapes to stimulate
quality right nobody's doing that the
way you could Inspire quality is if you
could criticize a person's performance
to their face like they're they did a
great thing on last week's It's Always
Sunny where where they get in trouble at
like Chuck E cheese
and they get sent to the punishment room
and Mac is with this little kid and like
the and like the person like talking to
them is like a therapist basically yeah
God please and uh he's like okay so you
guys feel okay do you feel that you've
expressed yourselves whatever it's that
whole thing yeah and Max like
this what is this this is like
you didn't make me feel bad about myself
don't you understand like shame is the
thing that is going to make me not be
bad again right it's it's funny the way
they do it I don't remember but like but
it's also really a great point of like
that there's no shame in any of this
anymore yeah you can't fire anybody
anymore because everybody will say you
discriminated against me for whatever
reason anybody could think of up to and
including I'm a straight white male and
I'm being just you know what I mean
right right like no matter what group
you're a part of you can now say you've
been discriminated against uh
everybody we live in a discrimination
everybody's lawsuit happy right nobody
wants to work no you know what I mean
like it's like it's like it's like you
know people running the businesses are
so exhausted that you can't dude I can
say I can say
the the the the the Flaming Hoops we
have to jump through at the bar to have
the reliable staff we have it's it's
astounding yeah it's astounding we're
lucky to have good people working for us
to find those good people it is climbing
Everest it's crazy it's insane it's
crazy like so so I don't know like every
time I every time I call customer
service I take a deep breath and I go I
know what this is going to be so have
those expectations now so you don't get
furious and every time it is that exact
thing every time and every time I go I
should hit record and hit this on
speaker and record it so when I hang up
because I know this is going to make me
Furious when I hang up I could just post
it on you know Twitter and just say hey
take a look uh hey Nike this was my
experience you know just right to cue
them in and every time I forget to do it
and every time like 40 minutes in I'm
like son of a I should have
recorded it dude I can't tell you
how many
friends
and I can't name names
I can't tell you how many friends I have
attempted to hire
to do things that I need done in the
various businesses that I am involved in
in my life because why because I believe
in them and I want to help a friend out
and Friends
I'm chasing them down not just going to
just happen to me you know that they go
yeah and I'm going what what is going on
yeah you know and and and it's never
anybody's fault it's never and I get it
work sucks the work environment sucks I
understand that we were all bred to live
to work and that's bad and we shouldn't
live like that I get it and I also get
that pandemic and all that stuff and the
lockdown was a big eye-opener where we
said what are we doing we need to spend
our time more valuable valuably but that
doesn't mean everything should just be
handed to you because you think you
deserve it it's so insane like when
the amount you have to chase a person to
just do their job it's like don't you
have an interest in eating do you not
have an interest in eating you know what
do not worry
I you know how much I worry about Jesus
Christ I'm about to turn 46 years old
what do I do if uh if I can't work next
year what do I do what do I do if I get
sick customer service you know what I
mean or something
what do I do I do not have the money to
retire what do I do I worry about that
oh uh this is Joe for Nike when you uh
when you when you especially win not I'm
not I don't want to make it sound like
if you own a business you don't I don't
mean like that but I think anybody who I
think there are a lot of it doesn't
matter I would say if from my personal
experience
owning and operating different llc's and
S Corps and whatever and you seeing the
the mechanism and how it works and
everything you know how fast it can be
gone yeah and when you know that
firsthand you understand like Jesus god
dude homelessness is only a few ticks
away it is not far away I don't come
from money my family doesn't have money
my parents were paycheck to paycheck my
whole life we had Christmases that were
very very light under the tree okay I
remember when I grew up in in the house
I grew up in it was a nice house but
like it was in the suburbs but we had
you could there was the the wood on the
lit on in the hallway of the downstairs
was exposed I don't mean hardwood floors
I mean the plywood was exposed because
my parents started trying to do a
renovation and they ran out of money and
couldn't finish it right and they
couldn't afford to put the linoleum or
tile down so we just had open wood yeah
on our floor downstairs like like we
like like when you don't come from the
money when there is no Lifeline of the
parent or the uncle or the whatever you
can reach out to you are very aware like
Jesus god dude like this this could turn
in two seconds and I am in that like I
am shocked at how many people just act
like it's just gonna it's a gravy train
man it'll just last forever and I could
do it as shittily as I want and they
will never do anything to me or fire me
or whether there's nothing in Jeopardy
and it's it's it's it's certainly it's
still weirdly an employee's market right
now so that's everything you're seeing
there is not the the threat of you will
be out of work is just now kind of
coming into right
because for a while for the last few
years they had they they had the
employers by the balls you know what's
crazier than I think about now with all
these tornadoes imagine being a bar
owner and a tornado just moves it
yeah that doesn't have insurance you're
done hip a borrower and it and a tornado
moves it a bar owner who is operating in
New York where the extreme heat makes
your air conditioning not work properly
sometimes uh operating in a city where
Spectrum internet goes out once a week
and you and you have to run an all-cash
register where in a world where nobody
has cash that's insane it's nuts it's
nuts my building has not had have had
hot water today's the
fourth day wow wow yeah something broke
it was over the holiday weekend nobody
or over the weekend nobody worked on it
or something and now they have someone
oh it's an electronic issue not a
mechanic whatever it is for I have taken
cold showers the last four days it's
like fix the goddamn thing but I don't
know how we got here my point always
everything's crumbling I said I didn't
want to go down the dystopian road but
we're down but the people that we're
talking about just by law of averages
are some of them are also our listeners
so they walk they walk amongst us is
what I'm saying you don't know who these
people are but nobody thinks listen
nobody this is the thing nobody thinks
they're that person nobody thinks but
you know if you are or you're not that
guy doesn't always
I don't know if I could do it
nobody is do nobody is who are you
nobody is doing it nobody's doing office
space nobody is doing Ron Livingston in
office space nobody is walking and going
look guys I don't really care about this
place you know what nobody's doing that
people are going in going oh my attitude
sucks yeah because I give everything to
this place and I don't get anything in
return and in some cases that's true I
am not somebody that thinks you should
bust your ass for the company I hate the
concept of a company man and all that
stuff I can't stand any of that and I'm
not even going to sit here and say that
I didn't slack off in my jobs uh and
that I don't that I don't ever slack off
of my courage and we all do it we're all
guilty of it but there's a flip side to
the coin where it's like dude you got to
show up and deliver you've got to do
your job customer service uh phone call
centers is the one place I am fine with
AI replacing
I disagree with you there I know I know
you I mean I know we're supposed to do
no I think that they should do I mean as
long as it's smart enough to handle the
problem it's it's oh okay
you've never screamed you know right on
the rag
on the reg I can be heard through the
hallowed walls of my apartment building
going because you're a
God damn it because it must be so
actually act for real it must be like
pretty fun living in your building and
living next to you and you're hearing a
guy like if I knew if I knew that like
my neighbor like
guaranteed two three times a week was
gonna be screaming at something or
screaming at the computer I would love
it I scream and inanimate objects
I mean it's it's once daily I used to
have a joke
where I said uh I said you screaming
here I scream at my computer so much I
people my neighbors think I'm an abusive
husband because I'm screaming at it like
it's a person and it's but it's like but
like that's why I don't want AI to take
like the the automated computer thing
makes me more mad than the people but
aren't you a Star Wars guy you don't
want a Droid I would love a Droid
I would like I would love a Droid but
that's uh
is that a I guess that is AI I was gonna
say they seem like actual intelligence
r2's AI yeah you're right you're right
you're right
it's coming eventually hold on here's
here's here's where Ai and the customer
service failed me okay this was I didn't
remember this this was last night
okay this was last night okay
hold on okay I used an app to get food
delivered folks I like to go to the
events what kind of events all kinds of
events sometimes it's a concert
sometimes it's a comedy type of thing
sometimes it's even a sporting event
with a guy like me uh and I'll tell you
what I really like to do I love to not
commit to things far in advance so I
like to buy tickets at the last minute
and I want to make sure I'm getting a
decent deal not just a decent deal the
best deal and that's where game time
comes into my life game time has made
buying tickets to my favorite events
stress free they've got killer deals on
last minute tickets with the breast best
price guaranteed and you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped about the fun you're gonna
have you can see images from where your
seats are that's the coolest feature
ever to me and I love that they've got
the Flash Deals on the last minute
tickets uh I love that it's uh all easy
to find and buy the tickets two Taps and
you're set yeah take seconds to do it uh
and they sent directly to your phone so
you never have to dig through your
emails for them we love the app we've
started using it immediately snag the
tickets without the stress with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code taste buds for
20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
taste buds for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
babe we got a bunch of bird dog stuff in
the mail again and I'm still loving it
yeah my old my old bulldog stuff I still
have you in my rotation and they are
still they look like new like they rate
these are quality garments yeah Quality
quality garments uh I love bird dogs I
just I also just got my my shipment of
stuff in the mail the new stuff and it's
exciting and I thought the same thing I
was like wow I've got new stuff but the
old stuff still looks looks new so uh
this is great anyway they make you look
good the stretch khaki shorts are
designed to fit Slimmer uh the shorts do
the exact same thing as Lou lemons but
fit way better yeah they fit way better
than regular shorts that are made of a
stiff restricting cotton also bird dogs
fix this issue how by inventing Cloud
knit fabric that looks just like khaki
but stretches so you get a way Slimmer
fit without having to sacrifice movement
I like a tight looking pant but I don't
like a tight feeling pants and it's
anti-stink sweat wicking fat fabric it
keeps you cool and dry all day long go
to birddogs.com taste buds and enter
promo code taste buds for a free Yeti
style tumbler with your order that's
birddogs.com tastebuds and enter the
promo code taste buds for a free Yeti
style tumbler you won't want to take
your bird dogs off we promise you folks
folks rosha here
here and rode this fall September
through December and carrying on into
the winter but right now let's focus on
those fall dates Avenal New Jersey
Toronto Ontario Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Salt Lake City Denver and
many many more dates are being added
constantly go to
joederrosa.com for all information
ticket links where the shows are
happening what the days they're
happening on is and then by the way for
all these I'm doing the I Never Promised
You a Rose Garden show my new hour very
proud of it I think you'll enjoy it also
go get that salsa windfall single mouth
on my money it's available now on All
Digital platforms and on August 4th the
full length album artificial birth drops
so excited for all of you to hear it
last but not least of course if you're
in New York come on down to Joey roses
seven days a week sandwiches good times
and drinks
joeyrosesnyc.com all right guys big news
I mentioned it before but December early
December I'm filming my special in
Chicago uh and I will not say where it's
going to be yet but the tour for that
special is ramping up right now starting
in August and going through to November
uh you can get tickets at savocano
comedy.com and these are some of the
tickets uh some of the places I'm going
now if this is this is coming out on the
13th uh with hey babe right so today is
July 13th the pre-sale is going on right
this second uh on sale will happen uh
tomorrow Friday July 14th so today is
the day if you want to beat everybody
out for those tickets the pre-sales
happening at savocano comedy.com and use
the code no pressure p-r-e-s-h I'm
coming through Bowling Green Cincinnati
Toledo Wilkes bar Wilmington Macon
Georgia Savannah Athens Georgia Peoria
Rockford Cedar Rapids Springfield
Illinois Duluth Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart IN uh Elkhart Indiana
um that is all uh in prep for the
special so go online right now and grab
those if it's not July 13th into hearing
this they're on sale so just get them
also
January is the Impractical Jokers cruise
with Eric Andre it's our fifth one and
we did it five times because it is so
goddamn fun so uh you get tickets there
get shipfaced.com and then of course if
you want to catch the Jokers on the last
weekend of this leg of the tour we won't
be touring it until 24. you can go to
impracticaljokerslive.com July 27th
through the 29th we're going to be doing
um St Louis Indianapolis and Nashville
at the Grand Ole Opry I hope to see you
guys on the road uh and I and I cannot
wait to do special so Chicago tell a
friend it's going to be great and this
is where Ai and and humans fail me
simultaneously and I was talking to you
about Nike and I forgot that this this
happened last night okay I used an app
to order food there's plenty of them I'm
not gonna name names I use an app to
order food and it said the wait time was
about 45 minutes
so at about
an hour I went to check the status and
it shows you where the car is
on a map yep that's coming to your place
right and I see that they're out when it
comes to you in a car what magical
burrow are you living in yeah
mine has my food I haven't had food not
off a bicycle yeah in I can't probably
can't I can't even remember probably get
it quicker it's not the truth so I look
at this thing and I'm like all right
this was estimated to be a 15 minutes
ago so we're at an hour now let me look
it's dinner let me look where it is I
see the guy and I see on the map I know
where he is
and it's at a restaurant I I literally
could do it right to the pinpoint
accuracy and I go huh
that's not where I ordered from I was
like is he picking up
is he waiting on someone else's after he
already got mine I go okay maybe they do
that that's the hustle so I I do
sometimes the app sends the guy too
quickly he already picked mine up right
and it's been one hour and he's at
another restaurant right now oh a
different restaurant yes oh yeah because
they got multiple that's exactly what's
happening so they do that they can do
that oh yeah they they that's all they
do is multiple words oh they don't get
one and then finish it and get one dude
I had a guy once go past my apartment
and then start going back Uptown because
he had another delivery and I was like
wait what are you doing so where are you
going and he was and he turned he went
all the way up then turned around came
all the way down and delivered my food
yeah so I'm watching so I go all right
well maybe he has to do that right so
then I'm waiting now it's an hour and
five an hour and ten
and I'm like this guy I have been
watching his car sit there for 15
minutes
so I was like if the food is not ready
at this other place I'm getting screwed
he's just sitting outside the restaurant
so I was like can I message him so I
went into message him and I just was
like hey are you in another place right
now
um because I I just I just noticed on
the app that for 15 minutes you haven't
moved and my 45 minutes is now an hour
and 10 minutes that I was waiting and he
doesn't respond and so I'm like okay so
then I go can I let me ask the app if
maybe this is common I don't know so I
go into SD app and I go
uh
I just wrote
hi
are drivers supposed to pick up multiple
orders when they're delivering our
driver stopped and waited at another
restaurant for a different order for 15
minutes and Counting
just you know whatever and then I get no
no response and so
it it comes oh no this is what happens
it goes high high blank oh now you could
call I mean what are you doing no call
there was no call okay I said they said
I know I know I know we're not saying it
I know the app you're talking about all
I do is call them and get the problems I
couldn't find a person to call you
Google
you can select one of the options below
if it's something else describe it I
just said our driver has been stopped
for 15 minutes at another location
so wait so so then then they they
respond back nothing what I'm talking
about because it's a computer I know it
is Joe I'm telling you what I went
through I'm not telling you I didn't
know it was a computer no I'm saying but
why would you think you would get any
other results I thought it would just be
like you know I don't know what it would
do maybe be like oh refund though I
don't know all right uh and then I wrote
that I just said hey I'm just this guy's
not moving and he wrote they wrote I see
you want to know more about the status
of your order to help narrow down your
issue please pick from below and they
didn't have anything so I wrote the guy
that the person has stopped Elsewhere
for another order and it's still there
after 15 minutes your rest and then they
just start texting me my estimated time
and then they keep texting me my
estimated time every five minutes and it
keeps going up every five minutes I'm at
an hour and 20 minutes now it's a
compute you never thought to go let me
figure out how to talk to a human well
you're asking
I was listening to yourself because I
get in touch with a human so listen all
right
I just hope you keep reading I said from
a food app then then the AI says thanks
for the info I'm sharing all the details
of your issue with a live agent who will
connect with you shortly and then they
literally say you are now connected to
our Live support agent Anna Nicole
Smith Aina Nicole so I'm like oh a human
being with even a name so I was like
great so I it says she'll connect you
shortly so I wait a minute I don't hear
from her so I write hi I'm just
inquiring if it's normal for my guy to
be like you know it said 45 minutes it's
one hour and 15 minutes he stopped
somewhere
and I get three minutes passes and she
doesn't respond so then I wrote Hi am I
connected to Anna Nicole in customer
service support
delivered I wait two Germans she doesn't
even answer I just wrote great service
thanks and that was it and then the guy
came he disregarded he disregarded my
text to him and then he just came up and
I was like I got a buzz and like I saw
the bag outside my door and it was
literally like an hour and 20 minutes
hit and I just was like I don't even
like I'm not gonna use this anymore
what
it just comes back full circle what what
is going on
every turn you take fails you the
society is crumbling there is no such
thing anymore of like or not no such
thing there is not the concept of that's
a business and it's operated by this
person and that person has these people
that work for them and these people do
these jobs and and that's going away
look at what we rely on on our
day-to-day life everything you get
delivered to you is by an independent
contractor who can sign up in five
minutes and be working through the app
itself
everywhere all your transportation
outside of airplanes is done like that
now it's insane Uber is insane let me
take you understand how insane it is yes
but don't you guys think inconvenience
is a part of life and this is just if
you were in the 50s it'd be a different
set of inconvenience I agree that
inconvenience I'd rather not have the
app call a place and have a guy delivery
go old school they don't do it anymore I
agree that inconvenience is a part of
life and that's part of the problem is
that we're such we've become such an
entitled uh but not inconvenience the
face of what you're expecting as service
you know what I mean that's unacceptable
because it is the reason all of these
Services work like this the reason this
house of cards system that we're all
relying on exists
is because they have made it slowly but
surely impossible
two things are happening it's either
being made impossible for your business
to operate
in it within the environment where you
can hire the people you need so then you
have to farm out to services like this
and then that becomes the norm or people
are greedy and say well instead of me
paying this money why would I pay it
when I could just do this other thing
and it's way less it will cost me way
less those two things are colliding and
what you're seeing now is is is an
environment where you can't get reliable
service for anything then on top of it
you're living in a 100 entitled curation
culture where we feel like if I have to
wait 30 seconds for It screw you I'm
being screwed I deserve better I deserve
it right now right and that's why every
movie that's in the theater is also
immediately available on your TV let me
go one step further with what happened I
then take the bag in my house I open the
bag there was like four dishes they put
two of the dishes on top were in those
like plastic like the black like bowl
with the plastic on top but the two
underneath were the old school like
pizza type ones that were or like foil
with the like white disc that you fold
over they put there's no Rhyme or Reason
to why they split how they were packaged
and they put the plastic ones on the top
so when I opened the bag the two ones on
the bottom were squashed and the whole
bag was filled with sauce and it was
squashed into well that's because it was
in his backpack sideways
why they even packaged it like that
right so now I have a problem with the
restaurant then I realized one of the
items that I didn't that I ordered isn't
there and they didn't give me a
substitute no one said it no one said a
word the app didn't say anything he
didn't say it so I go you got to be
kidding me I called the restaurant now
and they tell me that since I placed the
order
through the app they can't help me babe
and they want me to settle it with the
apps customer service I got news for you
I got news for you my jaw is on the
ground right now at your rookie level of
handling I've been around this block so
many times I could have avoided that yes
you could have how you
uh I mean we don't got time
I got news for you at minute 52 at
minute 52 I would have had a full credit
for this meal okay and then when the
meal showed up screwed up that I got for
free I would have gotten a double credit
folks this show is sponsored by better
help uh I had a time in my life uh that
I was kind of not too sure of what was
going on full disclosure my apartment
got burglarized it was a very very
traumatic experience and it was a very
stressful experience better help was a
service that I utilized in that period
during that period and it has helped me
tremendously if you're a person who in
the past has ever benefited from therapy
I am one of those people uh and my
experience has been that when you're
feeling in this way therapy can be a
great tool but connecting with the right
therapist and connecting in the right
way that's not problematic that's not
laborious that's not too much of some
bureaucratic system or something you
have to go through
doing it quick easily conveniently
affordably these are all important
factors and that's what I love about
Better Health if you think of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online it's designed to be
convenient and flexible you fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist let therapy be your
nap with better help visit
betterhelp.com taste buds today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help help.com taste buds exhausting it's
not exhausting it would have been it
would it would have I would have taken
care of this because what I thought was
going to happen is I there's no way
you're telling what you're telling me
you're inability to handle it well
you're telling me in in the same breath
as this full-on conversation is that I
should have called customer service for
help that's what you're telling me no
yes I don't you're wrong because you
don't want to get on the phone
you're a weird obsession with not
wanting to get on the phone what do you
mean you in the ass bit you in
the X versus
folks check back episode number three I
don't remember was but my point being is
I got F at every single turn and I
didn't by the way I believe
this app we never announced the battle
the battle is getting saved this app is
customer service nightmares that's what
this app is okay because it pertains to
it pertains to what we're talking about
okay because I'll go I'm gonna go in
harder now so we don't have a battle us
up we don't need to all right yeah well
keep a customer service number listen
this is a
podcast do not complain that there
wasn't a battle where human beings and
we had the best intentions and it is
what it is customer service listen to
what I'm saying to you but can I just
say my no you've said your point no no
it's crazy to me but how do you not
understand what I'm saying I understand
what you're saying of having to rectify
this not even the prospect the idea of
having to rectify this by then calling
customer service which should have been
your first move no where I'm expecting
at a 90 rate that they are going to keep
me on hold and not get me even more but
they didn't they wouldn't because I've
dealt with this customer service you
gotta try yeah it's speaking like now
it's like well they they wouldn't have
because I did it's like no
PTSD with customer service I was like
the last thing I want to do now that my
food is here crushed and missing
something is get on the phone
customer service before talking to the
chat bot is what I'm saying you
[Applause]
Nicole it didn't connect you to Nicole
she left you hanging and she's a human
she's not a human she's a human call
doesn't exist no she understands well
then why wouldn't the AI bot that is
Anna Nicole say anything
I got disconnected you're missing what
I'm saying to you there is no Anna
Nicole so jackpot just said there's a
person who connect to you too that's not
there that can't be out there what
happened it's exactly what happened I am
telling you something and you want me
then to dial an 800 number go through
prompts and then listen when someone
goes hello no I go I will tell you I
ordered food two hours ago and the guy
first of all from a spot for 20 minutes
and I got I called the AI first of all
that's not what the with the customer
service sounds like you want to call
them
I'm very interested give me the phone
give me the phone I guarantee you I get
you your full credit for that I want you
to do right now I know Timmy you can't
give me I'm not even opposed to you
right now you're yelling at me like I'm
challenging you but you're not listening
to whatever let me tell you what I'm
gonna do from now on net from now on
what I need to call customer service and
it's not I don't need to do it
immediately I'm doing it on this on the
podcast live I'm not you don't need to
do that this is what I'm saying why I
want what I want to expose
I'm probably fighting without a battle
it's great it's great you're you're you
made a mistake this is the mistake you
made you started trying to just don't
talk don't talk for a second just listen
I'll make like a customer service rep
yeah you started asking a computer
sophisticated questions that couldn't
answer thinking that would lead to
something it led to that computer
telling you to talk to a human being
that doesn't exist okay then they're not
equipped to handle my drivers listen to
what I'm saying then you get the food
the food is screwed up it's an hour and
whatever late whatever it was right then
you're pissed off you call the
restaurant so you do get on the phone
but you call the restaurant and the
restaurant tells you to go screw because
they don't care and they don't want to
deal with it right even though they're
the ones to pack the bag and they're
lying to you I say that to the guy the
human I go you're telling me I live near
I'm I'm a human you're a human I got
screwed here you're telling me you
didn't put my stuff in the bag and
you're not gonna fix it because you're
bound to the contract so the app I'm
calling you on the phone telling me I'm
your assistant because that guy at the
restaurant is thinking this delivery
service takes this percentage out of
every delivery okay I my his Attitudes
by their insurance yeah now his attitude
is going to be not my problem not my
problem which I don't like so it's
nobody's problem
I'm not saying I agree with it I'm
telling you I think that that's what his
take is yeah I am telling you something
I have had just learned something here I
have had this exact issue with this
exact service
stop looking for an answer and a
response and just saying it's happening
with every service I don't want to
single anybody else we all understand
that I'm telling you though I've had
this exact issue using this exact
service I'm not blaming the service I'm
just saying I've had this problem okay I
every single time from the jump have
said I am not talking to a chatbot I am
not typing into my phone right now I am
calling somebody I have called I have
immediately gotten somebody on the phone
from a country where they are farming
these calls I don't want to deal with
that I'm hungry
cold and squash listen
you made your life worse this is what
I'm trying to tell you just listen
listen you still had cold messed up food
and you still were frustrated and you
still ended up on the phone I'm telling
you something the first move at minute
51 that I do is I call this app's
customer service and within seven
minutes or less it's usually two or
three I am fully credited and I have a
free meal coming to me and at that point
I go it sucks that it's late but it was
free I'm not out anything now all right
I couldn't find a phone number on Google
the name of the app oh now I'm going
online
now you're going on
it says right there you have a problem
so I was led to believe they want to
help me and then at the three texts he
goes I'm transferring into a live agent
you get credit right now yeah you want
all right what do you need what do you
need to know what do you need to know
for real I need your information yeah
I'm gonna have to give over the phone so
you know I need your info we're gonna
have to bleep it on the air
what time are we at
all right uh maybe we don't maybe we
don't do it right now because we got
give me our guests coming in we gotta
get it's gonna take me four minutes do
you understand I'm gonna put my money
where my mouse is okay so I'm gonna put
my mouth on my money okay the new salsa
now
so do you need just my you should open
the app and give it to you listen can I
just tell you my
I thought this this gave me a little bit
of amusement because it was fun my
driver's name was dong
and there was no first no less second
name it was just dong d-o-n-g and I was
like I love the name
um I sure that's the other thing too
should I give him a one huh that's the
other thing too
this poor bastard is like buddy I'm just
trying to build a life in this country
right now like it's it's a it's a whole
it's a lot going on here
here no get
me uh give me the I need all the info
for the order non-communicative and late
is it one star is it two just don't
write the dragon
I feel bad I'm ruining his life give me
the order info okay
orders and then you're gonna put my
phone up to the mic so we can hear it
okay
all right here we go we're on speaker
put your mic up to this
is my bank account
[Music]
how can I help you
representative
this is how you do it
I understand you'd like to speak with an
agent to ensure that you get to the
right person to help how can I help you
refund
I understand that you're looking for an
update for an existing refund or credit
is that correct
no
[Music]
well instead you talked to a robot
asking it the sophisticated questions
yeah I don't know why the texting is not
is like less of a headache I don't know
his Instagram is right there I just
typed two sentences it's just sitting
okay you're sitting here you just yelled
that refund 14 times because I didn't
say the first time I just say yes
look how we on hold for food delivery
service
not many people have problems
yes now imagine I'm standing in my
kitchen holding a leaky sauce there
that's crushed
constantly typing
just sitting here
I'm just sitting here I don't have to
make an excuse this is a bad experience
so was what you did right but my point
was I didn't want to do this here my
experience is going to lead to something
that's not I'm hoping I'm not against
you I love how phone oh
this is and thank you for reaching out
into the grooving your refund for the
inquiry and please allow me a few
moments to pull a break out here so they
can well miss it's not my account it's
an account of my friends account that we
ordered through yesterday
no it's working
[Music]
the order amount was
83.78 and I need a full refund for this
order Not only was it 30 minutes late
and when we received the food it was
spilled and damaged from the way it was
packed and we called the restaurant and
the restaurant refused to compensate Us
in any way
it was also missing one of the dishes
[Music]
buddy as I said to you a minute ago it's
not about less stress or more stress
it's about results versus not results
I'm Gonna Get You results here in a
minute also in all fairness in all
fairness
in all fairness
okay but you were still dealing against
you it's us I'm talking about but also
too I gotta say something here you got a
65 dollar bill before tax you tip the
guy 10 bucks that might have something
to do with the way your food
uh that might have been pre I might not
that might have been pre-put in there I
think they said it on that and I didn't
realize when you're looking at a 13 tip
you should give 20. all right but who
cares the guy was
no I know but you know but you put tip
goes on first
he might have stopped off for a coffee
and said I mean screw this guy it was
three dishes it was like I just was like
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
telling you you got a 65 Bill and you
ten dollar tip well usually doesn't it
say 30 that's what I usually
no it was in fact it was 65 plus service
fee of eight dollars plus estimated tax
uh
which is a bill of what is that 73
[Music]
bill you threw this guy a tenor I mean I
don't know now you're including the
service and delivery charges that that
the place gets I'm just saying you get a
check bill it's about 83 I know but it's
it's I ordered ravioli it's a 70 bill
after tax
don't tip shame
that's only five dollars tax on a 65
Bill Joe I don't have answers for you
all right what's this
Bebop jazz
[Music]
we can only provide you only a partial
amount of 13.99
no Miss Miss no I need a full refund the
order was inedible unedible because the
one of the dishes that actually did
arrived was damaged and it spilled
throughout the entire bag and ruined the
rest of the order the order was
destroyed it was an hour it was 30
minutes late and ice cold or at least at
least a full credit before tip at least
so a 73 dollar credit
okay go back and check but we need a
full refund thank you
[Music]
Never by the way it's never taken
to show you it's 100 of the time and I
love the fact that you talked a big game
of a full refund in two minutes maybe
seven and you're on your third hold and
she's fighting you over 13. hold on hide
and hide no
hit the phone thing then hit hide
yeah
12 minutes all right 12 minutes and
Counting and you think she should come
back on and be like full refund peace
player we're about to find out no no
mind you now it's been it would have
been an hour and 27 minutes since I
ordered and I'm standing next to my food
and I'm Gonna Wanna Do go through this
no you would have been doing this at
minute 50 I keep telling you that but
this is why I did not do this all right
a minute 50 it was just late they
weren't going to do anything okay and
I'm gonna call someone my guy's not here
it's six minutes late I've called I've
called at minute 50 and said look my my
uh delivery person is sitting somewhere
yeah my Deliverance is sitting somewhere
the time keeps going up right
[Music]
yes yeah I know it's irritating the time
keeps going up you can't estimate this
amount of time and at that point you
would have gotten at least a partial
it's playing out
[Music]
alive and that's not what's happening
can you text our guests and tell them
we'll be out in two seconds yeah he's
out there
I love that Joe's good at Etsy and
customer service
this is amazing we should just cut out
with the Jazz
hold on
good sign she's been gone for a minute
here's you hello
please God
you know what they're doing in there
they're laughing at you she just picked
up the needle and put at the beginning
of the record again they're laughing at
you oh
yes
[Music]
but I can give you 79
that's perfect that's fine a full refund
back to the a full refund back to the
payment amount is fine I really
appreciate your help I need a some type
of confirmation number yeah because I
have to call back if it doesn't hit
it'll hit I'm not calling back it'll be
fine just ask thank you for asking can
you have a conference can you give us a
confirmation number for the refund a
reference number
[Music]
send to your email okay thank you so
much for your help that's a refund of 79
I appreciate your time thank you so much
take care
you too I still love you babe
refund
it's a bunch of holes I
I yeah 80 beans back in here come on God
bless you God bless you I love you too
might talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
Fool's gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to them